THERE IS RUMOR THAT HIS YOUNGER
SISTER IS LEADING.
>> SHE'S BARELY NOTICED AND
OFTEN SEEN BEHIND HIM IN
OFFICIAL PICTURE, BUT SOME
BELIEVE KIM JONG-UN'S YOUNGER
SISTER COULD BE RUNNING NORTH
KOREA.
HAS UNFETTERED ACCESS TO HER
BROTHER, THE BELIEF THAT SHE
MIGHT HAVE ASCENDED TO THE TOP
TEMPORARILY COMES FROM THE NORTH
KOREAN INTELLECTUAL SOLIDARITY,
A GROUP OF DEFECTORS WHO HAS NOT
REVEALED THE SOURCE OF THE
INFORMATION.
CNN CANNOT INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRM
IT.
>> I CAN SEE IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
SHE'S IN SOME SORT OF TEMPORARY
POSITION.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR THE
NORTH KOREAN SYSTEM TO RUN
WITHOUT ONE OF THE KIM FAMILY AT
LEAST IN CHARGE.
>> KIM JUNG IS THE YOUNGEST OF
FOUR DIFFERENT CHILDREN.
SHE WENT TO PRIVATE SCHOOL IN
SWITZERLAND UNDER ASSUMED NAMES
AND LATER TOOK ON IMPORTANT
RESPONSIBILITIES FOR HER FATHER,
LIKE INSPECTING SITES BEFORE
OFFICIAL VISITS.
KIM IL JEONG DOES SIMILAR TASKS
FOR HER BROTHER AND HANDLES
GOVERNMENT POLICY.
>> CLEAR'S AN EFFORT TO SLOW
TRACK HER ON TO BECOMING
SOMEBODY WHO IS IMPORTANT WITHIN
THE SYSTEM.
>> BUT AS FOR HANDLING ALL OF
THE STRESS AND PALACE INTRIGUE
OF BEING THE SUPREME LEADER.
>> IF IN FACT, SHE IS RUNG THE
COUNTRY AS SOMEONE IN THEIR
EARLY TO MID-20s, TO ME, THAT IS
QUITE ALARMING.
IT MEANS THERE'S SOMETHING
SERIOUSLY WRONG WITH KIM JONG-UN
AND THERE IS SOME SORT OF VOID
THEY'RE TRYING DESPERATELY TO
FILL.
>> AND THE MYSTERY SURROUNDING
HIS BROTHER IS DEEPENING.
KIM JONG-UN HASN'T BEEN SEEN
PUBLICLY IN MORE THAN A MONTH.
KIM IS NOT IN THE CAPITAL CITY.
ONE ANALYST SAYS HE COULD BE
NORTH OF PYONGYANG IN ONE OF
THREE DIFFERENT COMPOUNDS USED
BY THE RULE RULING ELITE AND
THERE IS ONE POSSIBLE.
>> THIS SUMMER KIM JONG-UN SPENT
A LOT OF TIME OVER HERE.
HE OBSERVED MILITARY PRACTICES
OUT ON THE BAY AND HE EVEN HAD
MILITARY PRACTICES TAKE PLACE
RIGHT OFF THE BEACH IN FRONT OF
HIS FAMILY HOME.
>> NOW ALL EYES ARE ON A BIG
EVENT THIS FRIDAY, WILL KIM
JONG-UN SHOW UP AT THE
ANNIVERSARY OF THE FOUNDING OF
THE RULING WORKERS' PARTY.
HE WAS AT THE SAME EVENT LAST
YEAR SHOWN IN THIS PICTURE.
IF HE DOESN'T SHOW THE CONCERN
OVER THE PUBLIC DISAPPEARANCE
WILL ONLY GROW, IF HE DOES,